feminism a mistake
um
broad question
just generally yes or no is feminism a
mistake here and then go around
uh
why why because I feel like those
there's a few steps that have gone you
know I'm saying they've gone they've
gone a good way you know what I'm saying
but certain times you can be taken a bit
far in it so I'll say no for now okay
um so when you say feminism then so the
initial idea of what feminism was meant
to be then yes women have the right for
equality and all that all those types of
things but from what it was initially to
what it is now they're not really
because when it started they were known
as terrorists they planned
assassinations okay well not that part
no but what I mean is like the idea like
the idea of women being able to do
certain things I have no problem with
that but then it's what's been created
from that to this new age feminism and
sometimes people call toxic feminism
whatever you want to call it uh Neo
feminism it's just a bit extreme and
that's and that's the one which we tend
to tend to see modern modern day okay
um for me I think it was a mistake I
lived a quite a feminist lifestyle for
quite some time not actively not
realizing but just being from this
culture and stuff and uh for me
personally I find it a mistake what do
you mean you lived a feminist life I'm
independent uh financially and all those
things and I kind of pursued my career
for a really long time I pursued my
academics so a really long time I really
appreciate all of that but um I think as
you get older you realize how
unfulfilling all of those things are and
when you're sold that dream for a really
long time you're so convinced that that
can't wait and you're so convinced that
marriage kids and becoming at all those
things that are more traditional can we
when really biologically it's the other
way around so for me I would say it's
been a mistake I'm curious what age did
you switch your thinking I've always not
realized I it was like this I never
realized it was just part of life it was
just like you go study you go carry on
and you become more creative but as I
became more academically astute I
realized that it's actually hindering
some of my more nurturing and like my
core values and so I would say that as I
turned about 26 I realized that I'm I've
got all of the things I need in life but
I'm not fulfilled so clearly I've been
sold the wrong dream no so I'd say
around then around 26. yeah what do you
think was feminism steak
um I'll say no only because I think the
general idea of why feminism was started
it came with good intentions I would
like to believe but I also support the
Dave Chappelle joke where he said
um the feminists should have
um picked a man to lead their cause in
it
um I think the problem is obviously
feminism started before social media was
a thing
um and now you've just got too many
people online
state in their opinions that just don't
need to be heard and they've just
radicalized uh sort of a pure movement
and just made it toxic
so out of the people that said yes what
good came out of feminism
well like the vote in that women women
getting to vote okay
and yeah I don't vote to be fair if I'm
honest that's another story yeah I'm one
of those ones I don't what do you guys
vote does everyone vote
I'm curious if you had to be drafted the
same as a man if that if you had to do
that in order to vote would you do it
absolutely no I don't care like I really
don't care about what's going on I I
don't feel I don't care enough about
these things in life to fight for it
because it doesn't affect my uh reality
so the laws and this that and the other
that it doesn't really affect my
personal reality enough for me to want
to go get drafted to vote yeah it's not
serious enough no it's interesting
because there is there is a certain I
won't name names yeah YouTuber that like
I was saying that I because I think
feminism from the beginning has been
freedom without responsibility so they
wanted the freedom to vote without the
responsibility of being in the draft and
a lot of people think that like that it
was something we had to fight for but it
was actually a freedom
um that men had because they had the
responsibility and and it's kind of like
I don't know yeah because we talk a lot
about how women were oppressed because
they couldn't vote but men would like
had to go to war and so it's like you're
that oppressed because you didn't get to
vote but your husband is now being
drafted and potentially killed and come
back with PTSD if he does survive and no
survival no therapy nothing like that so
I don't see how we had it so bad
comparatively I think everybody had it
bad I think we had it pretty good yeah
oh my God Julian I would have loved that
life so no I don't understand why we
were seen as the oppressed back then I
don't I didn't see as an oppressive I
didn't think it was one so I think men
were really repressed back then going to
war and all this stuff that they didn't
even know anything about and then being
forced to just do it I think that was
more oppressive than not being able to
vote
okay who else said yes
so what are you pretty much yeah okay
okay go ahead what do you what do you
guys think what Freedom did we get out
of them that was good I didn't say it
was good okay for Freedom um I don't
know what it is it's just more about the
option I think that's that was the main
thing is just having the option to be
able to do the same things doesn't
necessarily that you need to do the same
things but just the fact that it's not a
no if you want to I think that's the
main thing okay
do you guys think that women should be
equally drafted now that we can vote Yes
so front lines actually no yeah of
course Frontline front lines yeah equal
rights equal now why
because I mean if if women are equally
drafted then it's not like your
opponents are going to draft women
equally they are going to come in men so
you're just going to lose at the end of
the day no no we do it they do it it
becomes a whole worldwide thing and
women actually get the equality in the
whole world is going to follow through
with that no but what I'm trying to say
to you is is if if across the world
women want equality and they want the
same rights as men right so if you want
the right to vote which is fine I'm not
saying we shouldn't but why shouldn't we
I'd say the main reason why that's not
the case is because just like you've
seen in the whole ukurine situation the
women need to kind of be with the kids
yeah not if we subscribe to what more
than women say no they don't no no but
if if there's a war if the war kicks off
you've got men going to war if the women
go to war as well who's going to look
after the kids I know but we're
prescribing to what is supposed to
happen this isn't what is being taught
now what has been taught now is they can
do that and if they if that's what they
scream out from the from all the social
media and everything then we should give
them the opportunity but in real life
they don't want to do that no no
opportunity is fine that's fine but
obviously in reality you can't like if
you said all right women and men have to
go to war then who's going to look after
the kids no but they don't say they
don't go to war because to so what
you're saying is I agree what you're
saying but the reason that women say
they don't go to war is not because
they're staying at home to look after
the kids so what you're saying is women
women shouldn't be drafted because they
need to stay at home to look after the
kids but then what they would argue is
no we're not stay at home to look after
the kids we want equal back to you so
all I agree with you I don't know more
kicks off there's not a single woman
that's going to be saying that yeah all
the feminists will go choir I'm just
trying to solve the contradiction no
I'll get this yeah no that was my point
and there was like a clip of me that was
taken out of context where I said if I
had to pick between getting drafted and
voted like I would give that [ __ ] up
easy yeah I am I am scared I will not be
on the front lines I swear to God what
you want me to cook
what do you want me to clean a picture
swear to God I'm running to the kitchen
not walking yeah and I also think like
having so many options isn't necessarily
good for everybody I think it's like
having the option to do everything you
want doesn't necessarily mean you'll be
happier sometimes it can make you quite
confused and you get distracted and I
know I experienced that in my life so I
know that like feminism gave women all
these options to do whatever they want
but I don't know if that actually leads
to life satisfaction having too many
options you do realize right and I like
the fact that you're saying that because
this is one of the things that we see
when it comes down to things like um
comparison like like
and bodies right the most of the reason
why people unhappy is because they've
they can always compare into something
so if you've never had an experience
people can call it naivety but when you
have too much of an experience you're
always going to compare something to So
when you say it like that it's one of
those ones where they've told you you
can do all of these things and sometimes
when you actually do some of these
things you're like yeah at least then I
don't want it because
logically even when you when you go to a
restaurant when there's too many things
on the menu you can actually that's
that sounds good and that just applies
to life so that's why I don't think
having so many options is necessarily A
gift
um in life
feminists who disagree though
who said that as a feminist who disagree
why yeah because that's that's what
their whole movement is
um I feel
well I think and I know that most of the
reason
um that they come out on sale of these
things is because they're just trying to
prove that they can do exactly what a
man can do and the funny thing is when
it comes to men
hardly find any of us arguing and trying
to prove that we are stronger than you
are doing all of that even amongst
ourselves naturally you know when you're
in a room with guys everyone just kind
of knows where they belong and then just
automatically sort themselves out but I
just noticed that whenever women are
involved in that kind of equation then
things just go out of place and then
again
yeah so yeah I don't know I don't have
this have you ever I think Kevin Samuels
used to use the analogy of
um there's some TV show where they put
women and men on an island Fear Factor
no it wasn't it wasn't Fear Factor that
grills yeah and it was like where they
had to survive yeah and the woman like
they had to save within like two days
and the men were completely functioning
they need a bit Wi-Fi there by the
second the second week or something so
why do you guys think there's this
disdain towards men from feminists when
they say they want equality
I've got it they're just conditioned to
do it I feel like they're just told that
men are the enemy but if you speak to
many women and ask them about their
lived experience very few will say oh my
male boss was a nightmare or this man
was so bad they'll always say oh I had
this boss she was a right [ __ ] and it's
always a woman and all these and as we
all know like I know from being my
experience on social media with women
and stuff it's always been more most of
my difficulties in life have come from
other women so I always combine like my
lived experience with my thoughts
whereas I think a lot of feminists
haven't even even branched it out to the
idea of what is my life experience been
like have men actually been oppressing
me has it been more women stopping me
from progressing at work and if they
took a moment to actually reflect on
that they realized men aren't the enemy
and it doesn't mean anyone's the enemy
but men definitely aren't the enemy and
I think they're not given that option to
kind of um all given that encouragement
to reflect on their own experiences I
blame social media
because the loudest people online are
the people that have been scorned that
are just upset about stuff for the sake
of it so they're the people that are
just in the comments making all the
noise and then that kind of shifts The
Narrative of what people actually think
is normal when in reality most women
probably don't think like most feminists
she's a very small percentage of angry
women but they're vocals it kind of
magnifies it it makes him seem like
there's more of them than there actually
are just because they're the ones that
are the most vocal whereas all the
normal women that are just getting on
with their lives that don't think that
way they're just sitting there watching
they're not really entertaining yeah but
we're all women as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible